quando foi a última vez que vocês
fizeram alguma coisa pela primeira vez
eu 81 anos estou fazendo de teve pela
primeira vez estou feliz
estou um pouco ansioso eu faço muitas
palestras do aula mas aqui um pouco
diferente e espero que vocês gostem dos
pais
meu pai morreu com 94 minha mãe com 99
eu podia dizer tudo bem tem ainda um bom
tempo passado preocupar com isso bons
anos pela frente
na verdade os estudos mostram que a
genética responsável unicamente por 20
por cento aquilo que nos acontece
os outros 80% somos nós mesmo aquilo que
nós fazemos e o meio que nós vemos é
muito testemunho consciência muito clara
que envelhecer é uma certeza
envelhecer bem é uma escolha
eu comecei a fazer 80 anos com 29
naquela altura já era um cara bem
sucedido na vida forte saudável mas não
era feliz era muito tenso e um dia
comecei a me sentir mal sente dor no
peito foi um médico
o médico me encaminhou para o
cardiologista eu fiz os exames os testes
do lojista chegou para mim e disse não
tem nada por enquanto
mas vai ter se você não cuidar de você
mesmo se você não cuidar da sua cabeça
se você não procurar ser menos tenso e
com isso eu procurei um analista
procurei alguém que pudesse ajudar e
comecei as minhas primeiras sessões de
análise
duas vezes por semana comecei procurar
entender quem é que era uma abelha e
isso foi muito importante para mim
ganhar pra mim na minha vida tem sido
uma constante a com ar os períodos que
eu fiquei assim fazer a análise
eu fiquei sempre procurar entender o que
estava fazendo nesse mundo isso tem sido
muito importante para que eu pudesse
lidar com coisas que não são tão fácil
para mim pudesse seguir na minha vida eu
acho que uma coisa é o autoconhecimento
é fundamental é a todas as pessoas
deveriam fazer alguma coisa a para
procurar se conhecer melhor
precisa necessariamente de ter um
analista isso pode ser feito sozinho as
pessoas desde que a pessoa queira
investigar um pouco quem é que nós somos
quem é o cara está lá dentro de mim
quero estar dirigindo com as suas
emoções com as suas reações
isso não é nenhum trabalho de grande
esforço para a gente prestar um pouco de
atenção naquilo que nós fazemos aquilo
que porque eu fiquei tão triste ontem
porque eu fiquei tão alegre porque eu
militei com tal coisa e não com o outro
o conhecimento é fundamental ele nos dá
uma possibilidade muito melhor de
relacionamento e principalmente o
relacionamento com as outras pessoas
quando você conhece a si próprio você
passa a ser um cara mais compreensivo
com as outras pessoas com que você com
que você se relaciona
isso é extremamente importante o
conhecimento nos ajuda também a lidar
com o stress dos 13 existe de uma vida
sem estresse seria extremamente
enfadonha seria extremamente borges e
não seria uma vida agitada
o estresse existe mas ele tem que ser
colocado a nosso favor
e tem que ser administrada é muito
importante nós sabemos administrar o
estresse como é que administra estranho
parece complicado mas é muito simples
vamos combinar com o nosso com nós
mesmos é o seguinte eu só vou me
estressar com aquilo que foi importante
aquilo que é importante para mim eu
posso me expressar
esse é o primeiro passo o segundo passo
vamos definir o que é importante na vida
vou comprar cada ano 100 páginas e vão
começar a escrever as coisas importantes
vocês vão escrever duas três quatro
linhas no máximo pra mim as coisas
importantes da vida
sou o mesmo a minha saúde está centrado
e à minha família
se estiver bem o resto é o resto vocês
podem ver mas tem uma série de coisas o
trabalho de esportes tudo aquilo que a
vida tem que saber lidar com ela então
consciência muito clara que nós só
devemos não se estressar nós devemos
somente de repente saí do nosso eixo
com as coisas que são importantes pra
mim o importante é eu mesmo à minha
saúde ea minha família eu desde muito
pequeno
dando infância eu tive que conviver com
estresse aprendi a conviver com isso
eu nasci em uma família humilde
meu pai era um emigrante português
chegou aqui com 16 anos se casou com
minha mãe e eu nasci numa pequena
edícula atrás de uma pequena vendinha
que meu pai tinha aqui não muito longe
daqui no governo em uma hora o orgulho
da minha origem o orgulho da minha
família mas a saudade dos meus fortes
só que a natureza não foi muito boa
comigo no começo da minha vida eu até 12
anos eu era baixinho gordinho é muito
fácil um verdadeiro pudim muito frágil
meu pai me colocou numa escola tem que
ser onde no alto da página do ministério
ficava lá de manhã e na parte da tarde
ea travagem ficar convivendo com um
garoto de rua realmente garante rua
mesmo em um ambiente extremamente hostil
gente não era bullying não sejam sabe
que eu apanhei uma barbaridade e meu pai
dizia o homem não chora
só não chora que precisa fazer a gente
fazer alguma coisa aí comecei a procurar
como é que eu podia me defender contra
uma academia comecei em uma academia de
artes marciais como entrei lá me
matriculei comecei a a treinar treinar
treinar tem muito boxe competir e aí me
apanhar passar bater
isso foi importante na minha vida foi
minha produção esporte me trouxe uma
dose de agressividade muito tempo por
muito tempo que eu tive depois
dificuldade de lidar com ela e procurar
a administrar essa agressividade mas
isso me introduziu ao esporte e esporte
cê foi sempre foi muito importante na
minha vida
tem alguns títulos de campeão brasileiro
que o que mais me orgulho e sempre foi
realmente uma coisa que para mim foi
muito importante não só o esporte disse
mas para a saúde e também o mesmo
trabalho em todos os relacionamentos
todo o conhecimento que ele traz
nós vamos entender que o sport que o
corpo tem limite e nós vamos entender
bem pra que nós queremos o sport
acho que o esporte por esporte de
competição esporte lazer e esporte para
nosso bem estar para a nossa saúde e
também para longevidade com qualidade
eu durante muito tempo desde que o
esporte de competição e me identifiquei
com afinco sempre tive uma relação muito
clara com a derrota ou simplesmente
odiei sempre a derrota
então não tem muito muito muito no
esporte hoje pra mim o esporte tem que
está a serviço da minha saúde da minha
longevidade com qualidade para que eu
possa estar junto com a mulher com meus
filhos fazendo as coisas que eles fazem
acompanhando sempre
ainda hoje o exército todos os cinco
dias da semana com a com bastante a
atividade tem um programa de esportes em
todos os dias todos os cinco dias nos
outros sabe domingo eu faço alguma coisa
assim leve que tiver vontade de fazer
mas durante os cinco dias
eu faço esportes aeróbicos possui um
sistema importante para o sistema
cardiovascular faz um treinamento de
musculação treinamento de força porque
com o envelhecimento
nós perdemos as muitas células dos
músculos é importante que a gente
fortaleça as outras e faz também o o os
esportes e tem que aquele chamado um
pouco lúdicos um fácil triunfo joga o
squash ainda treino box
isso é importante para você manter o
sistema neural sempre ativo você fazer
com os seus músicos tempo tenham
agilidade mas não adianta a gente pensar
só em esporte
olhando para o corpo a gente tem que
pensar também na alimentação
a alimentação é fundamental para a nossa
saúde e para o envelhecimento com
qualidade
tem muita gente que pensa que
disponibiliza 50 tudo fácil alimentação
não gostei nada por ele só cobre salvar
só com verduras ou problemas o que não é
verdade
eu gosto de vocês gostam eu gosto de
feijoada eu gosto de lá eu gosto de
churrasco arte doce a eu gosto de tomar
a tacinha de vinho de vez em quando
só que eu não faço isso todos os dias a
todo momento eu não como um churrasco no
almoço e malásia no jantar e todos os
dias da semana
então realmente dá à alimentação
aquilo que engorda e faz mal é na
realidade
é regra é você fazer isso todos os dias
e sempre você tem uma alimentação
regrada
durante todos os dias a maior parte do
tempo e você simplesmente entediantes em
quando você sai de cobre faz aquilo que
você gosta esse é o ideal mas a gente
não pode o cuidar só do corpo a gente
tem que pensar também no espírito
tem gente que pergunta qual é a força do
milho onde esse cara tira a força dele
uma pessoa comum
absolutamente normal como todos vocês
se tem uma coisa que para mim realmente
é muito forte é a fé que eu tenho em
deus
isso realmente pra mim é muito forte
deus tem sido um amigão comigo ele não
tem evitado as dificuldades que eu te
encontrar na vida mas tem me ajudado a
superá las como aqui no caso do meu
seqüestro foi seqüestrado por um bando
de guerrilheiros e internacionais um
realmente uma coisa extremamente
profissional e a aaa foi colocado
debaixo da terra dentro de um caixote e
tenho certeza que é bom e que nos
primeiros momentos eu não conseguia
rezar não conhecia nenhuma conexão com
deus
pouco a pouco isso foi voltando e quando
fui voltando eu fui pedindo a deus deus
não me deixa perder a fé e aí quase que
por milagre
eu consegui sair dali são sol e pôde
continuar a minha vida
relações
hoje está provado consciência pelos
estudos que o relacionamento é
extremamente importante porque as
pessoas vivam bem principalmente para as
pessoas têm uma luta em longevidade com
qualidade
o relacionamento é extremamente
importante as relações estáveis
a monogamia são extremamente importantes
para que as pessoas vejam bem eu dou
muita importância dos relacionamentos
eu estou sempre reinventando todo mundo
sabe das minhas intenções empresariais é
o corpo empresa vendo outra saia daqui
vou trabalhar do outro lado e tal mas a
minha grande invenção foi eu ter me
casado há 14 anos atrás a agência de
natalie nascer rafael miguel
vocês não sabem o que é isso
hoje meus seis filhos dos quatro filhos
adultos
ana mais velha ari tem 57 anos e o meu
pequenininho t8 gente não sabe o que é
isso é isso aí dá uma força para
continuar vivendo
você dizer que eu tenho medo eu tenho
que me cuidar eu tenho que estar com ele
e eu tenho que estar bem então é
extremamente importante a maneira como
você se relaciona com o sensacional não
só com a família em torno de outras
pessoas
eu tenho muitos conflitos na minha vida
até conflito é normal não é desejável
mas pode acontecer
o importante é você tem os conflitos
você saber superá los e principalmente
você saber se reconciliar
se não ficar curtindo ódios e não ficar
curtindo uma água você tocar pra frente
e levar a vida
até porque tenho a consciência que nós
somos uma pessoa em 7 bilhões de pessoas
nesse mundo embora seja assim
nós somos únicos cada um de vocês que
está aqui é único e vocês são
insubstituíveis e quem é que vai
substituir cada um de vocês ninguém
quem é que vai substituir o abílio bom
pode substituir aquilo que eu admiro faz
fazer melhor ou pior não importa pra
ninguém vai substituir aquilo que eu sou
a gente tem que ter consciência disso e
aí realmente procurar a não taxe passar
já tô nessa vida saber que nós estamos
aqui eu tenho de sempre desde pequeno eu
sempre fiz uma escolha
eu queria ser alguém eu queria ser o
reino que passar por essa vida de uma
maneira marcante
isso tem relação com o dinheiro tem
relação com a postura na vida eu sempre
quis ter alguém dentro disso eu queria
meu propósito propósito sempre foi minha
meta principal sempre foi a felicidade
eu quero ser feliz eu sempre pois a
felicidade na frente como meta e tudo
que tinha um lado eu fui arrumando
ajeitando me direcionando para lá
a felicidade é grande mas tem dias que
você tá muito mal você está triste ele
está infeliz não são coisas que
acontecem na vida tem que administrar
você tem que seguir sempre rumo a ser
feliz
além disso tanto o meu propósito eu
sempre quis aprender e compartilhar
desde lá atrás que eu me formei na gv
não tinha emprego aqui no brasil está
pensando nos estados unidos você
professor
eu sempre quis aprender eu tenho uma
vontade imensa de aprender
eu tenho uma frase que eu uso muito o
que eu quero ser hoje melhor do que eu
fui ontem e amanhã vou querer ser melhor
do que eu sou hoje
tem gente que acha que isso é marketing
não é eu levo a minha vida assim
agora quero aprender e compartilhar eu
quero aprender e quero dividir com as
pessoas
é por isso que estou aqui é por isso que
adoro de ver é por isso que eu faço
palestras é por isso que acho que já
escreveu dois livros porque eu quero
compartilhar as coisas que têm
acontecido na minha vida e essa é a
idéia
esse é o meu propósito é isso que me
traz aqui se eu conseguir deixar alguma
coisa
com vocês que possa ser útil para vocês
na vida eu vou ficar muito feliz
[Aplausos]